hi I'm Emma Carmichael and I want you to
start off the week today with the right
mindset I want to remind you to follow
your passion and do what you are born to
do whether you're just starting off the
new business or trying to grow an
existing one do something today that you
can pour all of your heart into and all
of your passion into you create
something that you know will change the
life the person will be receiving it
create something that if you look back
ten years from now you'll be proud of
what you accomplished today and have the
courage to believe that even though it
might not make sense right now by
following your passion and my being is
helpful and significant the people as
possible you'll achieve all the success
you're after and one to help you along
your way I want to share some of my
favorite advice from Apple co-founder
Steve Jobs
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards so you have to trust
that the dots will somehow connect in
your future you have to trust in
something your gut destiny life karma
whatever because believing that the dots
will connect down the road will give you
the confidence to follow your heart even
when it leads you off the well-worn path
and that will make all the difference
sometimes life's going to hit you in the
head with a brick don't lose faith I'm
convinced that the only thing that kept
me going is that I loved what I did
you've got to find what you love and
that is as true for work as it is for
your lovers
your work is going to fill a large part
of your life and the only way to be
truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great work and the only way
to do great work is to love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't settle as with all matters of
the heart you'll know when you find it
and like any great relationship it just
gets better and better as the years roll
on so keep looking don't settle I've
looked in the mirror every morning and
asked myself if today were the last day
of my life what I want to do what I am
about to do today and whenever the
answer has been no for too many days in
a row I know I need to change them your
time is limited so don't waste it living
someone else's life don't be trapped by
Dogma which is living with the results
of other people's thinking don't let the
noise of others opinions drown out your
own inner voice and most important have
the courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to be
everything else is secondary
so good luck have a fantastic Monday do
something today that you're really
passionate about and Noah help people if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up and leave a comment below and
I'll see you soon
Oh
you